[Musique]
si demain vous deviez quitter la france
pour échapper au confinement ou
partiriez-vous sur une île paradisiaque
au coeur de la forêt tropicale
et bien sachez que le paradis des
français portent un nom monaco en effet
c'est dans la principauté qui se situe
au sud de l'hexagone que les français
sont de plus en plus nombreux à se
réfugier
il faut dire que dans ce paradis
bancaires et touristique le confinement
et le couvre-feu ne sont pas de mise
là bas il est possible de manger au
restaurant de se prélasser à l'hôtel et
de se baigner sans crainte que jean
castex viennent vous embêter
malheureusement et le phénomène n'est
pas anecdotique d'après le gérant d'un
hôtel interrogé par france info
il y à une hausse de la fréquentation du
segment français qui représentent 80 %
des réservations contre moins de 10%
l'année dernière à la même époque
visiblement monaco est un paradis pour
ceux qui aiment échapper à la contrainte
même si le quotidien est plus
supportable là bas il est obligatoire de
porter un masque et de faire attention
aux gestes barrières les gestes qui sont
toutefois plus facile à respecter sur un
yacht que dans le bus alors qu vide
monaco devenu l'eldorado des français
choqués alors on va pas se mentir
vous avez été à monaco et je vais
m'excuser maintenant je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi parce que moi j'ai
une garde alternée mes deux filles
habite à nice et que je descends en
général pour aller les garder pour
trouver les faire venir à paris et que
ben effectivement à monaco tout est
ouvert
donc le plus longtemps mais attention là
le travail au congrès il faut dire les
choses c'est que ils ont eu quand même
des règles en place et à dire c'est
ouvert mais à partir de 21h vous devez
avoir terminé de manger et est rentré
chez vous c'est à dire qu'il ya quand
même un couvre-feu ou à 21h30 tout le
monde doit être chez soi et à 21h tout
le monde par des restaurants donc vous
pouvez manger à 20h vous êtes accueillis
et à 21h au revoir mais je pense que on
peut comprendre ça et non je suis pas
choqué parce je pense qu'il ya un
ras-le-bol général les gens on vit
heureux et emilie va me sauter dessus je
sais mais non les gens les gens auront
envie de retrouver une vie normale
oui et là bas je me balade dans la rue
je vois des petits sourires
les gens pensent qu'on a vue mais il se
trouve que au début il avait dit on va
on maîtrise de virus et aujourd'hui
c'est une cataracte c'est un scandale
c'est un scandale et jeu mais je
m'excuse auprès d'albert qu'un prince
que j'aime beaucoup
on va s'excuser auprès désert ils ont
fait de monaco un cluster géants vieux
et le maire de nice christian estrosi
s'est élevé contre ce à juste titre les
gens voient mona cours reviennent et
ramène le virus une fois arrêté mais
c'est un monde de privilégiés gilles
s'installe on n'a qu'à fermer les accès
gisèle on n'a qu'à des travailleurs
français qu'on droit de rentrer à monaco
il ya que ceux qui travaillent à monaco
qui ont la carte monégasque au droit de
rentrer pour aller manger alors cela on
papa pas les touristes par exemple perdu
et touriste ayé c'est moi je trouve ça
tellement hypocrite de dire ah oui je
suis choquée parce que tout le monde dit
que machin a marre bien sûr évidemment
la vie était belle à monaco mais c'était
la même aux antilles j étais pas plus
tard que le mois dernier
il fallait voir le nombre de touristes
aux antilles qui pour échapper
effectivement pas ce qui est bien sûr et
à dubaï pour échapper au climat
anxiogène et ben ils étaient déjà mis en
valeur mais alors des parents très
strict s'il ya un problème parce que ce
qu'on entend le gouvernement fait passer
des messages mais visiblement et c'est
vrai que je décore et vous ceux qui
avaient la chance de quoi partir de
partisans seidman au maroc
oui et effectivement à dubaï est un
monarque et donc les gens qui reviennent
pas de test c'est pas normal parce que
les gens qui arrivent aussi parce qu'ils
arrivent avec des idées des tests qui
sont erronés avec des freak et ils
arrivent et ils vont contaminer aussi
les personnes que ce soit à monaco sa
sortie le film barney's soukeyna est-ce
que vous avez accès de façon privilégiée
au vaccin rro wee a et voulait
absolument je sais pas j'ai fait et je
ne sais pas encore fait plus 370 km les
ondes hospitalisation dans lost enix
soit les passions en hôpital de jour où
or not vitalisation complète ils ont
prévu
la incessamment sous peu de vexim alors
évidemment c'est 66 minutes qui avait
révélé entre une mais la sphère le
poteau rozehnal coton rose d'ailleurs
magadino pot-aux-roses
c'est bien trop roses n'étaient pas
compris la question mensuel écrit le
père au thé
donc c'est le monument culturel édition
merci magali on va dire qu'on extrait on
va t'on des coûts effectivement que
monaco bat là-bas tout est ouvert au
regard des monaco le paradis des grandes
fortunes où un habitant sur trois est
millionnaire deux kilomètres carrés d'un
îlot unique en europe
défiant la coved seulement 1000 cas de
contamination en un an
du coup la vie continue presque sans
contrainte
plusieurs centaines de touristes
français débarquent en masse chaque
week-end depuis l'automne
mathieu snet lui se frotte les mains à
la tête de son restaurant lorsqu'il y en
attaque
or puisque le restaurant est déjà
complet mais jusqu'à quand car en ville
les monégasques ne voient pas toujours
d'un bon oeil cet afflux porteurs de
virus précisé
moi je fais des allers retours à monaco
je n'ai pas attrapé kovy des attentions
sont très vigilants ils ont des règles
hyper stricte la police ils vous suivent
avec les caméras dans la rue si vous
voit sans le masque qui vous je ne sus
vous avez 100 euros d'amande et c'est
pas négociable
55 ans ils ont blindé c'est moins cher
avec la tolérance
vous avez la main n'y a pas de
discussion avant tout les cas maintenant
et on est arrivés tout à fait bienvenue
dans le monde réel vous est pris d'abord
merci beaucoup monaco on vous embrasse
et j'en passe que le parce que j'aime et
qui datent de tableau était pour moi